all right it's time for this week's pet
project lori herron joins us from nspca
brought along a very cute dog birdie is
with you today how you doing lori
i'm good thanks kendall this beautiful
dog birdie i'm trying to get her face so
you can see how cute
her face is she is an eight-year-old
coonhound bloodhound mix
she's very happy she loves to give
kisses
i don't think there's a family out there
that wouldn't that she would be a good
fit in she's
she does need to go on walks because
she's very active because of her breed
and she can do well with other dogs we
know that
she also will do well with kids great
family dog
and and kendall her story is the one
that we're seeing a lot these days where
somebody just couldn't keep her
um she was an honor surrender and with
her sister
her sister already found a home and now
we need a home for little birdie here
yeah and those breeds really are by
nature sweet uh
they have a sweet disposition very sweet
disposition
she's um she's just happy all the time
kendall
and she's also just a beautiful girl
she's very healthy
so there's got to be a lot of people out
there
um watching you now that bernie would be
a wonderful addition
and and as i said to you before the
break we at nevada spc as much as we
love them
our goal is to say goodbye and we really
want to say bye bye birdie
yes laurie it makes me so happy when you
drop the dad and mom jokes that's the
best
i love it all right so the families can
come hang out with birdie and check it
check her out and see if they all gel
and even if they have other pets right
yes and get covered with kisses she
loves guests
that is great i have no makeup left
well we hope birdie finds a new home
very soon thanks so much and she was
ready for her close-up too
she did she was not camera yeah she was
she's photogenic
yes all right lori good to see you take
care if you're interested in adopting a
pet
go to nevadaspca.org or you can call
them
at 702-873-7722